thank you
thanks for convening a short notice I
can't believe it
oh here we are
Atomic test
the Russians have a bomb
we're supposed to be years ahead of them
but
what were you guys doing in Los Alamos
and how many people were in these uh
open discussions too many
compartmentalization was supposed to be
the protocol we were in a race against
the Nazis
so now the race is against the Soviets
not unless we started Robert they just
fired the starting gun
[Music]
what's the nature of the class today.net
data indicates it may have been a
plutonium implosion device like the one
you built at most
a secret Laboratory
in the middle of nowhere keep everyone
there until it's done and why we don't
let's scientists bring their families
will never get the best
build them a town why would I leave my
family I told you you can bring your
family I'm not a soldier I'll be a
soldier
he's a general and I've got all the
soldier I need what can I tell them as
much as you like them so you feel my
boot on your balls you know Isotopes and
you're no explosives you can't tell us
what you're doing
why would we go to the middle of nowhere
for who knows how long a year or two or
three
before the Nazis though oh my God how
about because this is the most important
thing that ever happened in the history
of the world
here you go to little town
everybody will go crazy
[Music]
they both let me leave I won't let you
leave
happening isn't it
[Music]
I don't know if we can be trusted in
such a weapon
you can convince anyone of anything
even yourself never stand there's a
Japanese fighter
nobody knows what you believe
do you there were rumors of Espionage
unsubstantiated no proof there was a spy
at Los Alamos
[Music]
thank you
you felt your judgment was sound on who
won the team could be trusted no one is
leaving Los Alamos
[Music]
[Applause]
we had a moment where it looked like the
chain reaction from an atomic device
might never stop it are we saying
there's a
chance that when we push that button we
destroy the world chances are near zero
near zero 21 for Theory alone
zero would be nice
[Music]
thank you
for the Japanese surrender if they knew
what was coming
foreign